SHANNON LOW: My
name is Shannon Low.
Thanks very much, Brendan,
for the introduction.
I head up the Google
Play apps and games
business development team
for Europe, Middle East,
and Africa.
And I'm very happy
to be here today
to speak to you about how to
reach more users for your apps.
For this session,
I'll also be joined
by my colleague, Bruce
Kerr-Peterson, the EMEA
regional lead for
app developer sales.
So a quick rundown of what
we're going to talk about today.
First of all, I want to talk
about some of the things
that we've been doing to bring
more users to the Play Store
and to you.
I'll touch a bit on search
and discovery and some tips
to improve discoverability
of your app on Play.
Then I want to talk also a
little bit about best practice
to reach users outside of Play.
And finally, Bruce will also
talk about how to leverage
Google's paid
promotion solutions
to acquire even more
users for your app.
So let's start with
the marketing campaigns
that we've been running
to drive awareness
and bring more users
to Google Play.
Nice picture out here--
we've been investing heavily
in promoting Google
Play around the world
and running marketing campaigns
so that users know about all
the high-quality apps and
content available on the store.
This is an example of an outdoor
campaign in Waterloo station
here in London where we've been
featuring great apps and games.
We've also done
similar campaigns
in Piccadilly Circus and
New York in Times Square.
We've also been
running TV commercials
in several countries,
such as UK and Japan.
On the left, you see what we
call a "Play Your Heart Out"
television commercial.
And on the right is a television
commercial specific to games.
And again, these heavily
feature Google Play content,
including apps and games.
Here are some examples
of digital campaigns
that we've been running
in the UK and the US.
As you can see, Google
Play brand and the content
are featured prominently in
the mastheads of websites--
bring attention to Play, drive
users to Play in front of you
guys.
Obviously we are doing
campaigns on mobile as well.
We're running digital
campaigns in Korea,
a couple of other markets.
Here are some examples
of a rich media
mobile campaign that we have.
And this is what you can
see on tablets and phone
if you're exposed
to these campaigns.
And being Google,
we're constantly
pushing the boundaries,
figuring out
what new things we can do to
promote new apps and games.
Here's an example of an
experiment we did in the US
with editorial collections
and promotional videos
in the Google Play Store.
What you see here is a
page on the Google Play
Store with a video
front and center.
You click on that video.
You see a short
commercial of fun apps
that you might want
to use in the summer.
And below that is an
editorial collection
of those same apps that
were featured in the video.
So all that is about bringing
users into the store,
driving awareness, and
driving users to you.
Once the users are
on the Play Store,
how do they discover your app?
So that's why we need to talk
about search on Google Play.
I'll start with search.
For the average app,
search makes a large share
of installs.
I think we all know that.
As an app developer,
when a user searches
for something that's like your
app, what do you want to do?
You want them to find
your app first, right?
And optimizing
that process means
understanding the types of
searches that users are doing
and making sure that
the data for your app
supports these searches so that
we can surface these to users.
So what are the types of
searches that users do on Play?
There are two types of searches.
The first is searching by title.
This is when a user knows
exactly what they're
looking for.
They know the title of your app.
So all they do is just type
in the title of your app
into the search bar.
And they do that
search based on that.
What's important here?
The really important
thing to remember here
is that a high-quality
title is really, really key.
Titles are not just
about branding.
It's important to be as clear
as possible in the title
to communicate what
the app is about
and what it does
for the user, right?
Is your app about
internet radio?
travel planning?
Is it about podcasting?
Make this clear in
the title so that you
capture the attention
of interested users.
That also makes your app stand
out in a sea of competitors.
And it also helps us surface
you in relevant search queries.
Second type of
search that users do
is when they don't know exactly
what they're looking for,
and they're searching
by keywords.
And these keywords
might correspond
to features in your
app or characteristics
of your app or game.
So for example, my friend
might tell me, hey,
there's this new cool game out.
It has something to do with
puzzles and goblins, right?
So I might search for
puzzle games with goblins
and see what comes out of there.
What supports these
kinds of searches?
This is where your store
listing is really important.
Your app's description should
clearly tell us and tell users
what your app does and why
it matches to users, right?
Make sure that you get all
that information up front.
And once that's
done, then you can
brag about how
successful your app is,
all the awards you've
won and so forth.
But make sure front and
center right at the top
tells what your app
does, why it matters.
So getting users to
your store listing
to land on there from search is
just one part of the equation.
The other part is getting them
to download, hit that Install
button, convert
them in that way,
reaching the users that way.
So keep in mind that there
are many users out there who
judge apps by the quality of
the screenshots and videos.
Because if you haven't
downloaded an app yet,
there's no other
way you can tell
what that app is like when you
actually have it on your phone.
So make sure you have
high-quality screenshots
and videos that the
user can scan through.
And the more you can communicate
what the app experience is
like, the more likely it is that
users will download your app.
Of course, you don't
have to do all the work
when it comes to search.
Google Play is constantly
collecting statistics
about installs,
uninstalls, and install
retention and engagement.
And apps that are successful
in all of these metrics
are more likely to be highly
ranked in search results.
So what does that mean?
It means that the most
important thing you can do
is to create the best
experience for your users
no matter what your app does.
Because if you've got a
great app that users love,
they're going to install it.
They're less likely
to uninstall it.
If they do uninstall
it at some point,
they will keep it for a
long time, finish playing
through the game, whatever,
before they uninstall it.
And they will be very engaged.
They'll spend a lot
of time on your app.
And these are the signals
that we pick up on
to recognize what is
a high-quality app.
So sometimes users
might just want
to browse through the Play Store
and check on new apps, right?
That's discovery by browsing.
And there are generally
two categories
that browsing falls into.
The first is browsing
on the Apps homepage,
and the second is browsing
through top charts.
So when a user opens
the Play Store,
we all know where
the Apps homepage is.
You tap Apps, and then you get
to this place called the Apps
homepage.
And here is where
users can discover apps
from different clusters
and categories.
For example, they might
find new and updated apps,
health and fitness apps,
communication apps.
And this page is
personalized for each user,
so remember that.
So the Apps homepage is
a browsing experience
that let's Google
Play offer great apps
that the user may
be interested in.
And finally there's top charts.
So these lists, like
top-selling, top apps,
top grossing, top new,
trending, are common ways
that we provide for
both new and returning
users to quickly discover
the most popular apps.
So that's search and discovery
on Play, some quick little tips
on how to improve
discoverability.
Now I'd like to talk about a
few more concrete things you
can do to acquire users for
your app outside of Play.
So you've built your app.
You've published it.
You obviously want
to publicize it
on your website, marketing
material, ad campaigns,
social media
channels, everything.
Get it out there.
Remember to use Google
Play official badging
when you do that.
That's really important.
Why?
Because users are 47% more
likely to trust and download
your app when they
see that badge.
If you happen to have a web
service that accompanies
your mobile app or users
use your service across web
and mobile, it
makes a lot of sense
to also consider using Google
sign-in on your website
so that users who sign
in with a Google account
have the option to
send your app directly
to their device over the air.
It just works like
that, like magic.
You sign in one time
on your website.
The user gets this button
that says Install On Device.
You tap that, bang, it appears
on your device seconds later.
And what's even better is that
once the user is signing in
on your device, he's
also automatically signed
in on the app.
So there's no friction
at all in getting
that user into
your app that way.
So developers have seen
a 40% install acceptance
rate using this.
So this is really worth doing,
really worth trying out.
Now we all know
that social media
is really important
for acquiring users.
And YouTube is a great
marketing channel
for apps, especially games.
We have a huge audience of
potentially interested users.
And this survey by Blitz
found that about 95% of gamers
discover new games by watching
gameplay videos or trailers.
That's significantly more
than the percentage of users
who discover games by reading
reviews, going to game makers'
websites, and so forth.
So think about creating
a YouTube channel
to share your game trailers,
to share gameplay videos, game
tips, even user-generated
content around your games
if you're a game developer,
to engage and acquire
potential new users.
If you're an app
developer, think
about how this might
apply to you as well.
Maybe you want to create-- if
it's, for example, a utility
or productivity app, you
want to create a channel
that shares tips around
how you can use your app
to drive productivity
in your life.
Finally, one more thing you
can do to acquire more users,
which is if you have a
portfolio of apps, and your app
shows ads, you can show
free house ads using AdMob
and promote your
other apps for free.
This works because users
who downloaded one or more
of your apps already
know your product
and should be more receptive
to other apps that you offer.
So this is offered for free.
Try it out.
It's no harm trying, definitely.
So that's some of
the things that you
can do to acquire
users for free.
Now I'd like to welcome Bruce to
talk about how you can leverage
Google Play's paid promotion
solutions to acquire
even more users for your apps.
Bruce.
[APPLAUSE]
BRUCE KERR-PETERSON: Hello.
Thank you very much, Shannon.
It's always difficult to follow
something about paid promotions
when the last sentence is
about doing it for free.
So my name's Bruce
Kerr-Peterson.
I help developers find the right
users for their applications
through paid promotions.
You as developers
are just developing
these incredible applications.
Some of the things that
Ellie talked about earlier
are just brilliant.
The next step, though,
is to actually find
users to download and engage
with your application.
Today I'm going to show you
how you can drive discovery
and engagement through
our paid solutions.
There are millions
of apps out there.
Take some time to think about
how you could possibly leverage
some of these to actually
make your app stand out,
stand out from the crowd.
When I speak to app
developers, the first thing
that jumps to mind when
it comes to app promotion
is in-app promotion.
However, when you
think about your user,
your user can be found in
multiple different places.
And it's not just
about an app promotion.
Every day, our
advertising solutions
are becoming smarter
and more effective.
We currently have the
ability to advertise
on three great platforms.
There are 2 billion
video hours watched
on YouTube mobile per month.
There are 100 billion searches
on google.com per month.
And through AdMob, we can reach
900 million unique devices
per month.
So the question
really comes then,
how do you choose
the right campaign?
And that logic comes
down to the users
that you're trying
to engage with.
Do you just want those
users to download your app
and actually open it
for once, one time?
Or do you actually want
them to open that up
and take a very specific
action and continue
to open that up and take
very specific actions?
I was speaking to a
developer the other day.
She had done a lot
of market research
about her financial
management app.
And she found an app that could
really meet a consumer need.
She developed the app,
and it was brilliant.
The difficulty she was finding
was actually driving discovery
and getting that app installed
and for users to actually use
that app.
It's a common
conversation that I have,
and it's one of the
biggest problems.
You're out there developing
these revolutionary apps
that consumers and users might
not have even thought about.
The possibilities within
these apps are untold.
And that's why using things like
YouTube and TrueView campaigns
is such a great way to
explain what your app does
to the users that could
potentially be using it.
These campaigns help reach
people on YouTube who
are actively watching
or have watched
videos that are related to
applications like yours,
or have an interest
in similar apps.
Ad rules will only
show these ads
to people on relevant devices,
and not on desktop or computer.
One of the things that
YouTube is very well known for
is boosting awareness.
This is a great example of
when a situation has happened
and awareness has been boosted.
Game Of War-- Fire Age was
developed by Machine Zone.
It was the top-grossing
app on iOS and Android.
The goal for them when they
started their YouTube campaigns
was to drive a high
volume of engaged users
to install their app
and play it again.
Once they launched those
campaigns and the results
were in, they figured out that
the value of the users coming
from YouTube and those
campaigns were 15% more valuable
than any other video platform.
YouTube is an incredibly
powerful platform to use.
It can be used for both
branding and performance.
Performance and Google
search-- the two words
are very synonymous.
An increasingly more powerful
way to drive user engagement
is through the mobile
search network.
Mobile app install campaigns
on the search network
help people who are already
looking for apps or businesses
like yours find your app.
The key to creating
any successful search
campaign, as many of you know,
comes down to the keywords.
And Shannon touched
on it a bit earlier.
These keywords, and through
the new user interface,
can be generated through
pulling in keywords
from Google Play
and Google Search
to give you a few suggestions
that you could use.
In addition to
that, you can think
about what your
app actually does
and the functionality that
your app has within it
and use those words
in combination
with the word "app"-- for
example, hotel app, car app,
shopping app.
In addition to
that, you can look
at brand words, brand keywords
and long-tail keywords.
These are particularly
useful if you're
trying to drive towards a
very aggressive target CPI.
In addition to mobile app
install campaigns on the search
network, you also
have the ability
to use mobile app install ad
campaigns with extensions.
So it's not always
the case that you only
want to drive app downloads.
It could be possible that your
web presence is incredibly
strong, and you have
an equal preference
to whether you get a website
click or an app download.
So in this particular
case, using app extensions
like the ones described
by Rhonda Hanson
can be an excellent way to
give the user the opportunity
to do one or the other.
So as I mentioned before, one
of the most used advertising
platforms is through
an app or AdMob.
And these types
of campaigns drive
a huge volume of impressions.
Now, that volume of
impressions is a great way
to get your awareness
out there and to make
users aware of the type
of app that you have.
They're very easy to set up.
You literally select
your app and what
you want to promote
it on, and we'll
set up the rest of
the campaign for you.
In the long run, you can
use a conversion optimizer
as well to maintain that
campaign, that sustainability,
towards the target CPI.
The shift of the
focus in the past
has largely been on these
large burst campaigns that
would get you up the rankings.
However, what we see
more and more now
is marketers and developers
working on longer term
strategies to make sure
that they can profitably
drive these app downloads
and then follow that up
with engagement strategies.
As we've discovered,
in-app advertising
is one of the fundamental parts
to an advertising campaign.
App promotions ads are templated
to create text, banner,
and interstitial ad
formats, driving users
to either the iTunes store
or the Google Play Store.
These ads run on mobile
search, on GDN, and in apps,
and are the most
effective format
for driving app downloads.
Once again, reaching
the right user
is not just about
in-app promotion.
Developers and marketers are
looking at more holistic ways
to reach these consumers.
And that's done through Google
Search, the Display Network,
and YouTube.
And these can all
be done and managed
through the AdWords interface.
Remember, these ads are smart.
They're purpose built to
help drive app downloads.
The first step, as
I've just covered,
is very much about discovery,
driving app downloads.
The second step is
about engagement.
And this is really where you
get to push that lifetime
value of your users
and to increase
the profitability of
your app over time.
Users need to be kept updated
to what's going on in your app.
Otherwise it acts as a silo.
And they never
really know when you
have new updates or potentially
different games or levels
that they can play.
So through paid
promotion, I'll show you
a couple of ways in
which you can reengage
with those users over time
to sustainably increase
the profitability of your app.
So in order to do that,
there are really two ways.
The first is through
app engagement campaigns
on the Display Network.
These are app
engagement ads that
are targeted towards
users who already
have your app installed.
It encourages the user
to open up your app
and to engage again
with the content.
On the Search Network, it
is a similar principle.
App engagement campaigns on
the Search Network target
users who already have
your app installed.
They drive people
back into the app.
And the aim is to make the
action relate to the search
query that they have just
searched on to get them there.
So the question is, how do you
relate that search query back
to the content within your app?
And that really comes
down to deep linking.
For ads on the web, just
to give you an analogy,
you would have your
landing page example.com.
But driving users to
example.com might not
be the best user experience.
So we make it more specific.
If this user searches
for shoes, you drive them
to example.com/shoes.
That principle is
the same for apps.
It's just called deep linking.
So to give you a few examples of
how it could potentially work--
and some of these might
relate to the apps
that you actually have--
when a user is logged in
and they actually have
the app on their device,
they could search for
flights to Beijing
on the Google Search Network.
And you could direct them into
your app to flights to China.
Winter coats would be another
example where the search would
be winter coats, and
you could direct them
into your app on the Coats page.
And lastly, if the user was
searching for Boston movie
times, you could direct
them into your app
to the Boston Showtimes page.
To give you some gaming
examples as well--
because they are
kind of interesting.
If, for example, a
user was searching
on the Search Network
for a gaming app,
you could potentially
show them an ad
that's related to that
query if they once again had
your app installed on
their phone already,
or their tablet, driving
them back into your app
to a page that said Play Again.
And once again, instead of
them looking for other apps
to download, other
gaming apps to download,
you drive them back into
your app to reengage.
Or if you know
that your users get
stuck on a particular
level within your game,
for example, level 10, and they
would go onto Google Search
to figure out how
to beat level 10,
you could have an ad that
triggered for the search query,
"beating Game Of War--
Fire Age, level 10."
You could direct them
back into your app
to a page where they could
potentially purchase something
that would help them
beat that level,
or take them to a
special level where
they could progress from there.
So it's a very, very powerful
way of engaging and tailoring
your apps to your
specific audience.
So that's very much
on the Search Network.
On the display
side of things, we
fall back on something that's
slightly more traditional.
And that's remarketing.
So you can remarket in apps.
These remarketing
lists are created
once your app has
been downloaded
and you add people
to specific lists.
You can then retarget them while
they're engaging in other apps
with content that
is relevant to them
and can help them come
back into your app
and take a specific action.
I'll give you three examples of
lists that are commonly used.
So people who didn't use your
app recently-- so your app's
been downloaded.
You've taken the effort.
You pay the money to actually
have your app downloaded.
But your app hasn't been engaged
with in the past 30 days.
You could add that cohort of
users to a particular list
that you could retarget with
messaging that encourages them
to come back into your app and
either look at a new feature
or take a particular action.
But in that way you can
drive that reengagement.
If people are using a
specific version of your app
and haven't taken advantage of
some of the cool features you
might have developed,
you can once again
tailor a message to
them where you explain
some of these new features and
what they could potentially
use by going back into
your app and upgrading.
People who took a specific
action in your app,
if you know that a
percentage of your app users
are the ones that
monetize very well,
you could add them to
a cohort or a group.
And you could retarget
them with discounts,
or particular offers,
or new features
that they could
potentially purchase.
And in that way you're
really, really increasing
the lifetime value of that app.
And that drives
the profitability
of that app in the long run.
Now, when you think
of these two combined,
it becomes very, very powerful.
So you have the deep
link on one hand,
and you have the remarketing
and reengagement on the other.
But imagine if you combine
that into one ad format
where you can tailor and group
people into specific lists.
You then show them ads that are
very particular to that group,
and deep link them
back into your app,
where they can take
actions that are
very specific to the
particular user group
that they are and related to
the app where they'll find them.
It's an incredibly powerful
way of retargeting people
and increasing that
engagement over time.
And it's one in
which it's really
going to drive the lifetime
value and, as I said,
the profitability of the app.
So in closing, paid
promotion is all
about reaching the right
user at the right time.
It's always been about that.
The first step is
driving up discovery.
Shannon talked
about ways in which
that could be done for free.
And these are some of
the ways in which you
can do it through
paid promotion.
The second step is
consistently engaging
with that user over time.
Thank you very much
for all your time
and for consistently pushing the
boundaries of what is possible
so that we can all build better
products for our consumers.
I'm going to hand over to
Matteo, who once again is going
to talk to you about free ways
to engage with your users.
Thank you very much.